another episode of from has arrived
which means another episode making me
feel like I have a rod stuck in my head
although this episode was slower than
most there are still a bunch of new
Clues and Revelations that give us a bit
more insight into whatever the hell is
going on in this breakdown we're getting
rid of all the recap and focusing just
on all the theories Clues and Mysteries
I've left time stamps below so you can
see everything we'll be discussing let's
get into it this episode more than any
thus far hints at two opposing forces
using our townspeople as pawns and what
better analogy to show this off than
chess Kenny's father holds a chessboard
father caughtry holds a pawn and the
word Pawn is used rather pointedly is
that something here was talking to her
using her like
like a pawn chess is a game where pieces
are controlled by two opposing sides and
it seems like our townspeople are caught
in a game between good and evil when the
ghost of Father katri arrives he
explains to Boyd the importance of not
telling Kenny that Sarah killed his
father stating that it's better the town
stays unified and strong Sarah who
appears to hear voices from the
quote-unquote evil side tells Kenny that
she killed his dad causing Kenny to quit
his deputy and strain his relationship
with Boyd so it appears that the ghosts
like katri have the best interest of the
town's people at heart while the voices
that Sarah hears do not but we have to
keep in mind that not everything in this
town is as it seems closely tied to this
theory is Jim wondering if they're all
in some sort of experiment designed to
see how they would react he tells his
wife about the man on the radio who
somehow knew his name and that she was
digging either there is some sort of
informant in the group someone is
watching them or an all-knowing entity
that is keeping tabs on them Donna also
heard this voice so it's not just in
Jim's head but she tells him to keep
quiet about it until they can gather
more information the last thing they
need are the townspeople going nuts that
someone or something is watching them we
also don't know if this man on the radio
is good or evil he sure isn't helping
them in Donna states there are people
out there like the monsters who look
just like them but can rip your face off
so who's to say this guy isn't one of
them although there isn't much character
development for Tabitha this episode I
did want to talk about her first scene
where she's caught daydreaming out the
window my guess is that she's
experiencing another vision of the ghost
children evidenced by the fact she's
left the water faucet on eyes glued
outside and tells her daughter she's
continuing to see Visions I'm not
entirely sold that these ghosts are evil
if anything I think they need Tabitha's
help Sarah will later tell boy that the
boy in white for example wants their
help but isn't sure how and katri seems
to have their best interests at heart 2.
the end of episode 3 saw the return of
Sarah who we haven't seen since the
finale of season one Boyd is brought to
her and thus commences the worst
interrogation ever she basically states
that she followed him after he went into
the far away tree and ended up in the
church basement I don't know about you
guys but this strikes me as a bunch of
baloney now Boyd is in a predicament
because the town will want to get rid of
Sarah he wants her to stay believing she
has a special connection with this place
and that she may be the key to unlocking
its secrets and them finding their way
out and just a reminder if you like
these breakdowns be sure to like And
subscribe it really helps the channel
out and I plan on doing the rest of the
season plus I'm also covering Silo which
is pretty darn good last episode we saw
Boyd's shoulder cut open by Martin the
mysterious chained man this resulted in
him infected by these worm-like
creatures the same ones that could be
seen on Martin Boyd stumbles to the
ground as he sees the worms yet again
the implication being that these worms
are having an adverse effect on his body
we know that the monster's last episode
bypassed Boyd after he was infected and
now that he's infected he can see the
ghost of father katri is this merely a
coincidence or do these worms have a
deeper connection to this place Boyd
also withholds information to Christie
about where he got this cut just like he
didn't tell his son Ellis about meeting
the chained man in episode 3. he doesn't
want people to know about his illness we
also see the after effects of these
spider bites he got in the season 1
finale so between the worms spider bites
and the shakes we saw him have in season
1 episode 5 the writers here are really
giving us many potential misdirects on
the cause of Boyd's problems although
not a massive clue by any means Jade and
back to have something in common which
might point at who the town chooses to
suck into its pole both Jade and bhakta
had accomplished something fulfilling
before being sucked into town Jade had
sold his company and back to saved a
bunch of money to treat herself for a
vacation we also know that the town
chooses people who are running away from
something like father caughtry in season
one so this new clue will stay on my
radar gotta bring this up but found it a
bit weird that Mario was rummaging
through the medicine cabinet I get that
she's a nurse but it struck me a bit odd
especially considering there's no
patience there this new guy Randall sure
isn't taking too kindly to the town's
rules especially communal sharing and
he's particularly protective of
whatever's in his bag is that because
he's hiding something or he's just
really against sharing regardless Donna
moves Randall into this still
blood-stained bus and gives him a
Talisman to survive I expect Randall
will be up to no good going forward well
it looks like fanny pack girl finally
has a name Tilly which means Mighty in
battle an interesting name for someone
so frail and old she somehow knows that
Boyd has been on an adventure and as I
stated in my last video there's
definitely something going on with her
that's pretty much it for this episode
it looks like the town may be split in
two on what to do about Sarah's fate
with Kenny and Boyd taking opposite
sides but now I want to hear what you
think leave your thoughts and theories
in the comments below thanks for
watching be sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember I got a little
mystery boy sending people through magic
trees in the forest